be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life
stuff so as we get into part two of
Superman rebirth the son of Superman for
those of you guys who are just now
joining us from the last video we had
talked about how the last three or four
issues focused on Jonathan Kin it was
kind of giving us a rundown of his
character showing us who he was the
struggles he was going through and
learning that he had powers learning how
those Powers worked when he could
control them when he couldn't control
them but at the end of that comic we had
learned that Jonathan Ken had basically
fallen out of a tree and had been
knocked unconscious now Superman
responded to this with extreme
nervousness and the reason why was
because that should not have happened
Jonathan should not have been knocked
unconscious after falling out of a tree
the fact that he was says there's
something going on with him on a genetic
level and so the result was that uh you
know Superman and Lois Lane were going
to take their son to the Fortress of
Solitude now while this was happening we
had also seen the reintroduction of The
Eradicator now in DC Comics The
Eradicator has a long running history he
was around around long before the reign
of the Superman but reign of the
Superman was like his main thing that's
what most people think about when they
think about The Eradicator they remember
him as one of the four Superman who
emerged the other three being Conor Kent
Cyborg and steel but The Eradicator was
a little bit different where Superman
has the traditional powers of flight
super strength heat vision being able to
see through objects I guess xray x-ray
vision things like that everything
except lead The Eradicator wasn't the
exact same not only that The Eradicator
had an interesting history the way was
set up at least his origin anyway if I
remember this correctly The Eradicator
was the byproduct of you know satellites
more or less that had contained the
knowledge of a long extinct alien race
and those satellites had been sent out
into the universe when that race was
going extinct but you know those
satellites had been captured by a uh by
a cryptonia named camel I think and what
ended up happening is you know camel
destroyed all of those satellites except
for one and then corrupted and changed
the programming of that satellite to
preserve the entirety of Krypton even if
it meant wiping out all other races in
in the process to basically uh put
nothing above Krypton and The Eradicator
served that purpose but during reign of
the Superman The Eradicator of course
had previously been defeated but had
reemerged and The Eradicator was the
being that actually took the body of
Superman and put him in a regeneration
Matrix but The Eradicator did this for
the purpose of feeding on Superman's
solar energy and the reason why was
because The Eradicator couldn't just
absorb solar energy from the Sun its
body didn't work that way what ended up
happening is it absorbed the energy of
Superman and then used that power to
achieve its own goals the problem with
this and reconstituting himself is that
The Eradicator came to believe that it
was Superman that it actually was Clark
Kent and so it functioned in this
capacity now eventually of course
because the reign of the Superman saw
cyborg being the overarching villain
which led into Emerald Twilight and a
host of other changes in DC Comics at
the time uh The Eradicator fought
alongside the newly returned Superman
and Conor can't steel and a host of
other Heroes to to defeat Cyborg
Superman to defeat Hank Henshaw but with
the new 52 things are a little bit
different here and what DC tells us is
that with Superman SC being uh The
Eradicator his mind immediately flashes
back to re of the Superman it
immediately flashes back to The
Eradicator as he remembers him in the
pre- new 52 continuity and so to see The
Eradicator here means one of two things
either this universe has its own version
of The Eradicator who's just as bad or
The Eradicator from his reality from the
pre- new52 universe had reemerged and
had basically popped up inside this
new52 timeline and has basically begun
tearing things apart basically you know
is going to be a bad guy but regardless
of where this Eradicator came from
Superman's main goal is to defeat him in
every capacity that he can think of and
so while the two initially do battle
while they fight against one another
something I'd like you to take note of
is that The Eradicator begins using
phrases like we and it and us and I'm
sorry we and and us and so on and so
forth it keeps referring to himself as a
as an amalgamation of people as opposed
to just a singular being it refers to
itself in the plural basically and so
while Superman again is fighting against
The Eradicator in the midst of this
conflict chunks of the Fortress of
Solitude begin you know crashing down
and some of them threatened to kill Lois
and Jonathan and The Eradicator jumps in
the way and stops them from dying now
this is really interesting here because
Superman's just kind of like what The
Eradicator that I remember never would
have done that but this Eradicator seems
to be different now this is only on the
surface we'll actually see things are a
little bit different uh here in a couple
minutes but what end up happening is
Superman basically turns his attention
to Jonathan turns his attention to uh to
to what's going on with his body then
what we learn is that his genes are in a
state of fluctuation because of the fact
that he's half human and half Kryptonian
his Kryptonian DNA is overriding his
human DNA but sometimes his human DNA is
overriding his Kryptonian DNA and so
sometimes he has powers sometimes he
doesn't have powers now I would go as
far as to say this is really just
setting up a weakness for his character
that at any given point in time in a
conflict he may just lose one or more of
his powers and that he won't really be
resistant or won't be weak to Kryptonite
as far as I'm aware we've never seen
Jonathan uh exposed to Kryptonite now
we'll see that change here in a little
bit but for the moment right now he's
not he's never been exposed top
Kryptonite before and so this moment we
don't know whether or not he has a
weakness to Kryptonite but the fact
remains here that in the end the goal is
to find a way to cure him of this
illness or at the very least to find a
way to work around it but what we also
get is the backstory of The Eradicator
here in the new 52 and what we're told
is that instead of being you know a
satellite that was basically that
basically contained a ton of knowledge
belonging to an extinct race and being
corrupted what these eradicators would
do is they would find these criminals
who were on zod's list they would absorb
their souls and they would put their
souls Into The Phantom Zone then they
would take their bodies and they would
put their bodies in cryostasis they
would basically isolate the soul from
the body now once it came around time
for their trial they would restore the
soul to the body and then they would
undergo the process of however you know
their trials underw but if they were
found guilty their whole body soul and
all would be confined to The Phantom
Zone in its entirety and so what
happened is that in the middle of this
process one of the eradicators the only
one left bore witness to the explosion
of Krypton he washed it all die and in
the last moment before everyone died he
absorbed all their Spirits he absorbed
their Essences and so basically this
Eradicator contains the essence of
almost every single Kryptonian that's
ever existed the only exception to this
as far as we know is Superman who was
basically sent off now we have to
believe and I'm not super familiar about
Supergirl's whole origin story in in the
new 52 right now but we have to believe
that with her escaping she of course
wasn't confined there as well but I'm
sure somebody will will probably correct
me when it comes to Supergirl uh I don't
know but uh the fact remains here that
with Superman making his escape and
getting away the purpose of these
eradicators was to basically reunify the
Kryptonian race to take every single
cryptonian that exists and to bring them
unto itself and then turn around and
basically give birth to a New Crypton by
terraforming a planet presumably Earth
and then giving all those uh all those
Spirits bodies to live on as new
individuals and so Superman for him is
this is absolutely insane and the reason
why is because in the eyes of The
Eradicator Jonathan's human form is is a
hindrance it is it's it's an impure Gene
that is thrown into what The Eradicator
considers to be a pure Gene it's
effectively polluting the gene pool and
so The Eradicator intends to eliminate
the human genes from from Jonathan and
then absorb him into itself along with
Superman and give birth to a new Krypton
and so because of this you know
Superman's like no way that's not going
to happen and so Superman initially
tries to do what he can but The
Eradicator absorbs everything around it
which includes crypto the dog this is
one of the saddest things I've ever seen
when crypto dies it's it's it's pretty
depressing to see here but because of
the fact that Krypto has effectively
been killed Superman lashes out at The
Eradicator and uh and Jonathan just kind
of is left to his own grief now
initially Jonathan wants to fight here
he wants to fight alongside his dad
against The Eradicator but he's also a
little bit hesitant here and the reason
why is because the death of Goldie the
cat still weighs on his mind and his
mind the last time he used his powers it
led to the death of an innocent life and
he doesn't want to make that same
mistake again but what what Lois says is
that Jonathan is the best of his parents
he is his mother's confidence his
mother's strength and his mother's
courage combined with his father's
abilities and his father's moral compass
he has all the tools he needs to be a
great superhero all he needs is to
understand when to use those powers and
to choose to be the person that he's
that he's destined to be to choose to be
the good guy and so Jonathan puts on his
suit and he basically starts fighting
against his father this is a really
really cool moment in in D this is a
really cool moment for the Superman
story and the reason why is because
we've never seen Superman with a sun
before and so we've never had the
opportunity to see what would happen if
Superman fought side by side with his
son with Batman we've seen that we've
seen Damen Wayne fight alongside Bruce
Wayne but with Superman we've never had
that opportunity and so this brings this
scenario to us it brings us a situation
where Superman fights alongside his son
while simultaneously teaching his son
how to be a superhero and so because of
the onslaught that the two of them bring
onto The Eradicator it's not fully able
to to battle against both of them at the
same time with their combined power and
the result is that The Eradicator body
is effectively torn open and all these
Spirits begin to emerge out into the
planet from the Fortress of Solitude now
it creates a massive huge explosion but
the problem with this is that on these
once these Spirits emerge they realize
that krypton's destroyed and they didn't
know this when they were inside The
Eradicator they didn't know that Krypton
had been destroyed they just were
absorbed inside The Eradicator and they
were feeding him his power the problem
with this is now they're angry they're
angry and they're panicked and they're
sad and they don't they they they don't
know what to do and so because of this
everything begins to spill over you know
into the city of metropolis and what
ends up happening is that these Spirits
you know once this this portal seems to
be open these Spirits just pour in and
begin possessing these various
individuals inside a bar called the Ace
of clubs which is run by a guy named
bibs they start pouring into this place
possessing all different kinds of people
now at the same time that this happens
bibs because he's such a huge Superman
fan all owns all different kinds of
memorabilia but he also has a Little
Rock and this Rock was something that
was given to him or that he found and he
always kept it around here the problem
is that when Superman and Super Boy gu
Jonathan arrive inside this bar you know
when they crash land in here they
immediately begin to lose their powers
and this is when we learn that Jonathan
does have a weakness to Green Kryptonite
just like his father green Kryptonite
will kill him it'll take away his powers
and kill him and so this is when you
know Lois realizes this Little Rock
houses Kryptonite you know Green
Kryptonite inside of it now of course
she takes a green Kryptonite sends it
back through the portal and so it's no
longer a problem for them anymore but in
this panic in this this ensuing chaos
what ends up happening is Superman has a
vision and the vision that he has is
with his father Jonathan and what
Jonathan says is that it's the duty of
the living to carry on for the name of
those who have died and so effectively
Superman has to be the voice for the
dead kryptonians those individuals who
are from his Heritage he is their anchor
to life and In This Moment of clarity he
basically is able to communicate to
commune with these spirits and to calm
them down and to say yes you know
Krypton is dead but I've managed to to
make my way without my home planet you
can do the same thing but almost
immediately after this happens The
Eradicator shows up and reabsorbs all of
them back into himself again and so from
this point things just break out into
another conflict but instead of Superman
staying to fight The Eradicator he grabs
Jonathan and Lois and he immediately
takes off now the perception of these
these onlookers at you know at the Ace
of clubs bar is one what's going on here
with this new
Superman and two why is he running away
like Superman the Superman they knew
never ran away why is this new Superman
running away maybe he's a coward or
something like that but what happens the
Superman actually has a plan now
Superman's idea is to race off to a bar
it's to basically I'm sorry it's to race
off to a not to race off to a bar it's
to go get drunk Superman's idea is to
race off to a uh to a peer to one of the
docks in Metropolis and when he gets
there he grabs a submersible That's
rated for the deepest trenches of the
earth meaning that is able to to
withstand extreme pressures and what
happens is he takes a submersible along
with with Lois and Jonathan and he takes
him to the moon now the reason why he
takes him to the moon this is actually
really really cool what we learn is that
Batman has a has a bat cave on the
moon he's got bat caves everywhere uh
but he has a batcave on the moon now the
way Superman learned about this is that
because he was the new kid on the Block
and because Batman didn't know anything
about him because the other Justice
League members didn't know anything
about him Batman of course began spying
on you know spying on him and so
Superman got tired of being spied on by
Batman and decided to turn the tables
and start spying on Batman himself and
the result is that he had basically
learned that Bruce Wayne had built this
bad cave for the purpose of being able
to experiment with different devices and
things like that without actually having
to you know worry about blowing up
Gotham City or killing innocent people
but the fact remains here that this this
room we would or I guess this base we
would have to believe you know has safe
rooms it has places to protect Batman
from Superman if he were to go arai and
start killing off you know various
superheroes and things like that and
decide to kill Batman or something along
those lines we'd have to assume the
Batcave would have something like that
which of course it does and so so as
soon as they get there you know The
Eradicator is not far behind and so The
Eradicator begins fighting against you
know Superman and he tells Lois and he
tells Jonathan to get out of there and
to go find someplace safe now during
this conflict between the two of them
there's a lot of banter that goes back
and forth but this portion of the story
actually focuses more on Jonathan than
it does on Superman while The Eradicator
taunt Superman basically says that his
his family is his weakness because it's
something that can be targeted which
will make Superman desperate Superman
says no that's not the case his family
is a strength because it gives him a
reason to keep on fighting but during
this conflict Superman's Spirit his soul
is absorbed into The Eradicator now this
is really interesting here and this is
actually a dichotomy between the powers
that The Eradicator had in the pre new52
and this new52 version of The Eradicator
and the pre new52 of course like I said
you know it fed on the energy of
Superman to power itself in the new 52
it feeds on The Souls of dead
kryptonians to power itself and the
result is that by absorbing the energies
of Superman into itself its powers are
bolstered even further further now the
reason why I say this portion focuses on
Jonathan is because Jonathan lashes out
of the fact that his dad's Spirit has
been absorbed and he tries to fight
against The Eradicator of course
Jonathan's not really able to do much
because The Eradicator is so powerful in
this form but the fact remains that for
a kid he's still able to hold his own
but at the same time he's still
terrified like he's horrified one he's
sad because his father has you know been
absorbed but two because he's
overwhelmed by this circumstance his
life quite literally hangs in the
balance his mother doesn't seem to be
able to protect him and he's just kind
of on his own now while he's being
taunted by The Eradicator while he's
trying to face off one of the coolest
things happens right here Lois Lane
begins rifling through all the different
artifacts that Batman has inside this
cave and where Jonathan fights Against
The Eradicator Lois emerges wearing a
giant bats suit now this bat suit is
called the hellbat suit and that's
actual that's actually a really awesome
name but this is so cool because it
gives us a chance to see a mother and a
son fighting against The Eradicator more
so than that this tells us Lois Lane is
not a pushover you know Lois Lane is not
just you know she's a far cry from who
she was way back in the 40s where she
was just the Damsel in Distress now
she's resourceful she's intelligent and
she had been this way for quite some
time but with this DC rebirth it's a
return to what we know lowest Lane yes
she's capable but she's not just a
capable reporter you know when it comes
down to it you know she hasn't where it
counts and this is exactly what we see
with her both her and Jonathan tearing
Into The Eradicator as best they can but
again you know The Eradicator being able
to shoot energy beams which by the way
this is really cool because this is kind
of a homage to how he was in the early
you know in the 1990s during reign of
the Superman he didn't have laser hision
he shot energy blast but you know doing
the best they can in the end they're
just not able to really stand against
his might and so while The Eradicator
and you know Lois and Jonathan are
fighting one another they I guess you
know while they're while they're
fighting each other we pick up with
Superman inside the body of The
Eradicator and what tamasi what Peter
tamasi does is he basically kind of goes
back and forth you know in this he kind
of gives us the the fight between The
Eradicator Lois and Jonathan but he also
gives us Superman talking to these
spirits and what he says is that them
you know these individuals these these
Souls powering The Eradicator is not
what they believe it to be he's not
going to lead them you know to Paradise
you know he's not going to lead them to
predition instead you know he's
basically using them for his own source
of energy he's a bad guy the only way
for them to truly achieve peace the only
way for them to achieve freedom is to
bond themselves to Superman and give
Superman the strength to destroy The
Eradicator which they do and so what end
up happening is Superman basically
forces himself out of The Eradicator
body and starts tearing into him I mean
really just starts starts giving him the
business and this is one of the coolest
things this is one of the coolest
moments because there's so many homages
there's so many Throwbacks to to the
idea of the Superman and The Eradicator
fighting one another because this is
just really hearkens back to the reign
of the Superman it really hearkens back
to the various conflicts that Superman
and Eradicator had over the years and so
with the battle you know raging on with
the battle you know stretching down into
the the core into the depths of the Moon
the various punches and the various hits
ended up resonating throughout the
moon's surface and causes a series of
moon Quakes now the reason why this
matters is because this draws the
attention of NASA and NASA begins using
their various modules to look around the
moon and as they're poking around and
once Superman and Eradicator emerge from
the Moon NASA immediately Zooms in on
them and NASA is just kind of like oh my
God you know there's a new Superman here
we've got to display this guy for the
world to see we've got to let people
know what's going on and so they begin
broadcasting this footage across the
world and so the whole world stops the
whole world is standing still and it's
watching this new Superman fighting
against The Eradicator now during this
conflict as they're going against one
another because Superman is so powerful
because The Eradicator you know lost
virtually all of its Spirits except for
one The Eradicator power is at 10% of
what it used to be but we learn that
this final spirit inside The Eradicator
it's actually crypto and so what happens
as Superman reaches down into The
Eradicator body it tells you know he
tell tells crypto to bite onto his arm
and he pulls Krypto out of The
Eradicator leaving him completely
powerless with no energy to feed off of
and the result is just like any machine
without any kind of power source it just
effectively shuts down you know and
that's what happens exactly with The
Eradicator he simply shuts down and then
he's destroyed and he explodes and
that's it all the energy is let loose
and there's really nothing left of him
anymore and so what we do here is we
basically pick up with a with kind of a
celebration it's it's not wildly
important but it's basically you know
it's it's DC telling us that Superman is
here to that Superman you know the the
new the pre- New 52 Superman is here
he's not going anywhere uh that may
change at some point along the line but
for right now it's the pre- New 52
Superman that we've all grown to know in
love and so once they get back home
Superman is basically greeted with the
key to Metropolis the world seems to be
celebrating the fact that their most
iconic hero is here you know that he's
back alive even if it's a different
variation of the one they know but more
so than that we pick up with Jonathan
Kent a Superman gives Jonathan glasses
and a hat and this is one of the reasons
why this this is so cool because it is
Jonathan basically getting his own
secret identity you know it's his own
little way to be Clark Kent you know of
course Clark Kent's glasses are symbolic
here the hat that he wears is symbolic
here but more so than that this is
probably one of the most important
things a Superman takes Jonathan to the
Justice League watch to and he
introduces Jonathan to Batman and to
Wonder Woman and he says this is my son
Jonathan this is super boy effectively
inducting him into the Justice League of
America and of course while Wonder Woman
is ing on Batman's just grimacing
because he's Batman that's what he does
so anyway this this this wraps up the
story guys um I hope you guys liked it
you know there's an epilog for this and
issue number seven you know let me know
if you guys want me to cover it I'm I'm
kind of curious to see how if anybody
would find that interesting but you know
this is one of the best Superman stories
that I've read a long time to be quite
honest with you guys this was pretty
darn good so uh let me know what you
guys think and uh yeah if you guys uh if
you guys enjoyed this video drop a like
make sure you hit the Subscribe button
join the Rob core and uh leave a comment
and I will catch you guys later peace
you are
[Music]
the